a couple of hours ago a fatal crash has
completely closed the 215 southern
beltway westbound at valley verde we
have a live picture from a traffic
camera so traffic is being diverted off
but we also have our own
photojournalists on the scene and here's
what it looks like as traffic is being
diverted off the westbound 215 southern
beltway up there at that exit ramp the
nevada state police highway patrol is
giving a briefing so armando is going to
head up there in the meantime let's head
on back to the traffic computer and talk
about how you should skip the 215
southern beltway westbound closed by a
fatal crash happened after 6 a.m stay on
the northbound side of the 95 515 i-11
you probably make better time even going
around that
big squeeze area meantime westbound
flamingo has the right lane in the
center lane closed after las vegas
boulevard right there in front of
caesar's palace they've been there for
more than an hour squeeze to the left
and you'll get through please be careful
out there